non plus les feux de foraine ne nous
affectent pas tout de suite parce que le
bois qui est dans les cours à bois ben
il a fallu qu'il soit coupé puis a fallu
qu'il sèche il y a des semaines et des
mois qui se sont écoulés mais les
prochaines récoltes se feront plus plus
menus alors on sait bien que un jour ou
l'autre on va payer en quantité en
qualité de matériaux faut mettre les
choses en perspective ce qui vient de
l'Extrême-Orient c'est à peu près 50 à
70% de ce que vous allez trouver dans
n'importe quel quincaillerie il y en a
quelques-unes qui sont un point
d'honneur par rapport à la vague d'achat
local de d'acheter le minimum de loin de
l'étranger mais quand même il y a au
moins le tiers de ce qu'on retrouve dans
le sur leur tablette qui va venir
principalement de la Chine mais quand
même si je peux vous rassurer c'est que
le bois il vient d'ici quand je dis
d'ici ça peut être du Québec ça peut
être l'Ontario ça peut être c'est pour
ça que vous êtes touché par les feux de
forêt en ce qui concerne ce type de
produits là mais les matériaux de
construction que l'acier le béton ne
serait-ce que par défaut en raison du
poids ça peut pas venir de loin ça vient
du continent nord-américain et puis
souvent d'ici la même chose pour le
gypse même chose pour la laine isolante
donc là je viens de nommer des grands
des grandes catégories de produits
surtout si on déclinait tous les types
de bois du 2 par 4 ou 2 parties en
passant par le contreplaqué quoi le
contreplaqué il vient surtout de l'Ouest
là ça va finir par nous impacter mais de
façon générale pour tout ce que j'ai de
mentionner ça vient pas de Chine donc on
est un peu protégé puis l'autre aspect
c'est que
la covid nous a appris des choses
heureusement avez-vous réduire votre
dépendance à l'Asie dans la foulée tous
ces problèmes là on a réduit ça joue
d'un joueur à l'autre d'une bannière à
l'autre mais on a travaillé fort pour
faire deux choses que l'administration
portugaise du Grand Vancouver essaie de
faire c'est à dire on a automatisé dans
nos usines ici pour arriver à des coûts
plus compétitifs par rapport à ceux de
la Chine et puis
en fait je ne parle d'un autre aspect
qu'est-ce qu'il est revendique aussi non
seulement par rapport il a
sous-traitance donc on essaie toutes les
entreprises canadiennes essaient de
trouver des pièces des composants plus
près que d'attendre éventuellement
Shanghai qui n'arrive pas toujours
monsieur Darvault le quand on parle de
50 à 70% de certains produits qui
proviennent d'Asie du Moyen-Orient là ça
va toucher quoi là l'automne les
produits saisonniers l'hiver ça touche
l'outillage l'outillage électrique
l'outillage par pile on en fabrique pas
ici
toutes les fabriquer aux États-Unis
qu'on fait venir c'est quand même pour
une certaine catégorie souvent pour les
entrepreneurs professionnels alors ce
que monsieur et madame tout le monde va
utiliser quand on regarde l'étiquette
souvent c'est Made in made in China donc
là il va y avoir un retard parce qu'il y
a déjà plein de conteneurs qui attendent
à souper puis avant couvert puis on a
plein d'autres qui sont sur les bateaux
qui peuvent pas accoster donc là on
risque un moment donné d'avoir rupture
de stock et Noël
encore est-ce qu'on a le temps de
rattraper ou encore quand la chaîne
d'approvisionnement est déréglée ça
prend certaines quelques semaines ou
quelques mois rattraper ses enfants je
parlais du mot cascade ça va ça va nous
impacter mais à moins que le conflit ce
se règle rapidement et que et que les
feux finissent par vous réclamez une loi
spéciale monsieur Darvault non on
réclame on veut la paix et une belle
paix négocier ça serait encore mieux
mais si jamais on est encore dans la
même situation dans une semaine
peut-être vous pouvez me réinviter
peut-être j'aurais changé d'idée bon
écoutez
on a l'impression que dans les
circonstances vous êtes encore capable
d'attendre un petit peu à quel moment ce
sera le point de bascule et ça deviendra
urgent
si les trois niveaux de gouvernement
font ce qu'ils promettent de faire c'est
à dire de relancer notamment le locatif
abordable à un moment donné il va
falloir avoir toutes ces composantes
tous ces matériaux la pression va
devenir fort mais tant que les taux
d'intérêt sont élevés ben je veux dire
le consommateur est relativement
tranquille on s'en sort donc c'est comme
si c'est un mal pour pour un bien mais
moi j'ai l'impression que les trois
niveaux de gouvernement vont s'y mettre
on en entend parler et là la pression se
rassure les matériaux et puis s'il y en
a pas beaucoup on va faire face à des
hausses de prix ce qu'on a vécu vous en
souvenez durant la pandémie on va pas
retourner dans ce film clairement pas
clairement pas monsieur darvaux merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là ce soir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]